Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Tokös. Ich bin zuständiger Ersten für Sie. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Jürgen Lausin.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestellen?
Ja, der Vorname ist Jürgen, J-U-Umblaut, R-G-E-N.
Und Lausin ist der Familienname, L-A-U-S-I-E-N.
Herr Lausin.
Ja, genau.
Ja, freut mich Herr Lausin. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 79 Jahre.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie aktuell?
Ja, ich wiege so 84 kg und ich bin 178 groß.
84 kg, 1,78 m groß.
Okay, verstehe. Herr Lausin, vielen Dank.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerde haben Sie?
Ja, mein Hausarzt schickt mich her.
Wissen Sie, das gefällt mir alles nicht.
Gehen Sie mal in die Klinik.
Ich bin da hingekommen.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich letzter Zeit sehr schlapp bin.
Dass ich kein Appetit habe.
Ich schwitze nachts unheimlich.
Und brauche also ein bis zweimal, muss ich mich umziehen,
weil ich total verschwitzt ein Schlafanzug an habe.
Und, ja, was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ich habe immer so 99 kg gewogen
und mit einmal wiege ich eben nur noch 84 kg.
Ich habe also 5 kg in relativ kurzer Zeit in 3-4 Wochen abgenommen.
Das fand ich jetzt schon ein bisschen ungewöhnlich.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Lausin, Sie haben schon gesagt,
ich fühle Sie sich schlapp und Sie haben schwitzen, aber mehr als früher.
Ich schwitze, ich schwitze.
Ja, ja, und kein Appetit.
Haben Sie schon bemerkt, Ihre Vergrosserte schüttelten?
Das habe ich ja, also was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass mein, dass mein Hals ein bisschen so Schwellung hat
und dass ich meinen obersten Heldknopf nicht mehr zu bekomme.
Das ist mir so aufgefallen, ja.
Dass es mit einmal zu eng ist.
Verstehe.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Ja, also ich habe mich die letzten Tage fieberig gefühlt
und dann habe ich mal gemessen, weil ich ganz überrascht,
dass ich tatsächlich über 38 hatte, ja.
Wann und wo haben Sie Ihren Temperatur gemessen?
Ich habe, ich messe immer unter dem Abend, ne?
Und das war Abend, das ich gemessen habe?
Ja, abends.
Ja, kurz nach dem Schlafen gehen.
Und haben Sie auch Schüttelfluss?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht, nein.
Aber nachschweiß ich dann.
Ja, ich schwetze ziemlich in der Nacht, ja, das ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Sie haben auch fünf Glow in der Nacht drei bis vier Wochen abgenommen.
Verstehe.
Und haben Sie auch Yukkoreis?
Yukkoreis?
Nein, das ist mir eigentlich jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ich trinke, ich trinke schon hin und wieder mein Glas Wein,
oder ja, also ein Glas Wein trinke ich auch regelmäßig,
kann ich schon sagen.
Ja, wie soll ich ihn fragen?
Haben Sie, wenn Sie die Linke noten, vergesst, die Linke noten?
Das könnte sein, ich habe das, ich bin da jetzt nicht genau draufgekommen.
Das ist nicht mein Fachgebiet, ne?
Okay.
Wenn Sie Alkohol trinke, haben Sie diese, beispielsweise ihren Heißbereich, Schmerzen?
Nein.
Aber Sie haben Ihren Heißbereich eine Vergrößerung?
Also ich habe das gemerkt, dass da eine Schwellung ist, die aber nicht wehtut.
Und ich habe das halt gemerkt, dass das Hemd zu eng ist, ne?
Okay, verstehe.
Aber ist das Kurup oder Struma?
Was das ist, weiß ich nicht, ich bin kein Arzt.
Ja, verstehe.
Ich meine vergrößerte Schiedrüse.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, es ist hier am Halsgeschwoll.
Ja, ich habe nicht gehört.
Ja, Halsgeschwoll.
Ihren Leistungsbereich vergrößert die Linke noten bemerkt.
Wie gesagt, ich bin kein Arzt, ich bin Mathematiker,
ich bin kein Arzt, da müssen Sie sich schon drum kümmern.
Okay, verstehe.
Herr Lasien, Sie haben Fieber und ist Ihnen übel?
Nee, richtig übel ist mir nicht, ich habe nicht so viel Appetit,
seit mehreren Monaten schmeckt es mir nicht so,
aber das mir richtig übel ist, kann ich nicht sagen.
Keine Erbruch, aber Sie keine Erbruch, okay.
Das hat mich nicht übergeben, nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Wie ist Ihren Appetit, schlecht oder?
Ich habe doch gerade gesagt.
Kein Appetit gesagt.
Das habe ich doch eben gerade gesagt,
dass ich nicht Appetit habe.
Ja, und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Ja, also ich muss schon 2-3 Mal in der Nacht auf die Toilette.
Ja, aber ich meine, ich bin noch 79 Jahre alt,
was will ich erwarten, ja?
Ich bin noch 79 Jahre alt, 2-3 Mal, Sie müssen in der Nacht urinieren.
Muss ich auf die Toilette gehen, ja, genau.
Aber haben Sie Probleme auch Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang habe ich keine Probleme, nein.
Stuhlgang, okay.
Haben Sie heißungen Attacke?
Heißungen Attacke habe ich nicht, nein.
Ich bin eher Appetitlos, aber heißungen Attacke kenne ich nicht, nein.
Attacke, okay.
Keine.
Haben Sie auch die andere Regionen Schmerzen?
Beispiel Wurstschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen, Nein.
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich da eigentlich gar nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot und, haben Sie Atemnot?
Atemnot habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Also ich fühle mich nicht mehr so belastbar.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, ich kriege keine Luft mehr, ja.
Ich fühle mich einfach schwächer.
Okay.
Aber können Sie, wie viele Stocke können Sie gut treppensteigen?
Wie viele Stockwerke ich hochgehen kann?
Also gut würde ich mal sagen, ein bis anderthalb, danach wird anstrengend einfach, ja.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Ich schlafe ziemlich flach, ja, mit einem Kissen.
Okay.
Ja, Sie können nachdem ein anderthalb Stocke, Sie haben Atemnot oder Hörstöre.
Nein, ich fühle mich schwach.
Ich fühle mich einfach dann schwach.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon auch Ihren Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Das ist richtig.
Ist mir nicht so aufgefallen, Will.
Okay.
Gut.
Leiden Sie an Herzstrasen, Herzklopfen und Herzstoffen?
Nein, ich meine, das habe ich doch auch gerade gesagt.
Ich habe keine Herzprobleme.
Okay, Herzstoffe.
Herr Leisen, haben Sie früher chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, die Erkrankungen...
Ja, also, was ich habe, ich habe schon lange in Bandscheiden leiden
und deswegen Rückenschmerzen, deswegen nehme ich ziemlich regelmäßig ein Ich-Iboprophäen
und ja, meine Blutfettwerte sind ein bisschen erhöht
und deswegen nehme ich abends in Wasser Thin
und was ich noch habe, ich habe so Probleme mit der Binderhaut der Augen.
Da habe ich so eine chronische Binderhautentzündung,
da nehme ich immer Augentropfen dreimal am Tag, in jedes Auge eintropfen.
Okay.
Wie viele Inverteidoseen nehmen Sie Iboprophä?
Das sind 600.
Ich nehme 7 Tag Iboprophä, das ist auch bei mir.
Eigentlich jeden Tag, wenn ich ehrlich bin, jeden Tag, ja.
Ja, wie viele Mal nehmen Sie ein?
Einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und Sie machen Stattin, in welche Doseen nehmen Sie Sie?
Das sind 40er.
Ja, sich.
Und nehmen Sie am Abends?
Die nehme ich am Abend, ja.
Okay.
Und sind Sie...
Sonst noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nee, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ich hoffe nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie die anderen Medikamente ein, die Iboprophä,
Sie machen das in Augentropfen, die anderen.
Sonst nehme ich nichts ein, nein.
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente ein.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Jetzt muss ich weit zurückdenken, wurde ich schon mal operiert.
Vielleicht in der Kindheit, ja, ich klar,
natürlich in der Kindheit habe ich mal den Blindarm rausbekommen.
Blindarm.
Aber sonst?
Blindarm rausbekommen.
Ja, genau.
Und sonst noch etwas?
Nicht, dass ich mich erinnern könnte,
nee, sonst bin ich noch nie Untermesser gewesen.
Ja, als sicher zuständig, ich möchte etwas fragen, Herr Lasien.
Haben Sie Ihren Beinen Schwelungen bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Gut.
Ist Ihnen, ja, rauchen Sie?
Nicht mehr, nicht mehr, nein.
Ich habe vor 18 Jahren, habe ich, habe ich mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Vor 18 Jahren?
Ja, das waren verschiedene Gründe, aber auch finanziell,
das war einfach wahnsinnig teuer,
und ich habe hier das versucht,
jetzt mal mehr abzugefüllen, ja.
Super.
Und davor, wie viel Zigarette haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, habe ich schon ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja.
Und seit wann haben Sie, wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ach eigentlich mein ganzes Erwachsenenleben,
ich würde sagen so 30 Jahre habe ich schon sicherlich
den Erwachsenenleben geraucht.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie, Sie habe schon gesagt,
trinken Sie Alkohol.
Und wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie?
Hab ich Ihnen auch schon gesagt, ich trinke
ein bezweigender Wein am Abend,
ziemlich regelmäßig.
Okay, seit wann?
Seit ich jetzt im Ruhestand bin natürlich
verstärkt, aber eigentlich habe ich das schon
mein ganzes Erwachsenenleben gemacht.
Vielleicht so 40, 50 Jahre.
Muss ich hierher.
Okay.
Herr Leisen, Ihren Baum...
Mein Name ist Lausine.
Lausine.
Lausine, ich schuldige.
Herr Lausine, haben Sie Ihren Bauchumfang,
vergrößerte Baumumfang bemerkt?
Nein, eher im Gegenteil.
Ich habe ja 5 kg abgenommen,
insofern mein Bauch ist nicht mehr geworden.
Nur da oben am Hals wird es eng.
Okay.
Aber haben Sie auch Ihren Nägel
Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Sie meinen bei den Fingernägeln?
Ja, Fingernägel, ja.
Weißen Nägel, ich meine.
Weißen Nägel.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Diese Frage ist nicht persönlich.
Es ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie Droge?
Nicht Drogen, nee.
Aus dem Alter bin ich nur wirklich raus.
Nein, habe ich auch nie gemacht.
Super.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Das wäre ja ein Wunder, wenn die noch leben würden, oder?
Ich bin 79 Jahre alt.
Wie alt müssten meine Eltern sein?
Ja, und Sie sind...
Sind Ihre Eltern verstorben?
Ja, natürlich sind sie verstorben.
Aber in Deutschland, die Menschen leben sehr alt.
Ja, also wundert es, sind sie nicht geworden.
Ja, also wundert es, sind sie nicht geworden, nein.
Okay, woher gestorben Ihre Eltern?
Könntest du es mir jetzt sagen?
Mein Vater hatte einen Kielkopfkrebs.
Und meine Mutter war schwer dement.
Okay.
Wie alt war Sie, wenn Sie gestorben?
Meine Mutter ist mit 78 gestorben.
Und mein Vater war schon 73.
Ja, es tut mir sehr leid, mein Beil jetzt.
Ja, das ist ja schon eine Weile her.
Demenz.
Und haben Sie Schwester?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Und ist sie gesund?
Ja, kann man nicht sagen.
Sie hat einen Schlaganfall und ist seit dem Halbseitig gelebt.
Und ist also hilfsbedürftig, ist nicht mehr so gut drauf.
Aber ja, also sie lebt aber noch, ne?
Wie alt ist sie?
73 ist es bei einer jüngeren Schwester.
Okay, wieso leiden Sie an Schlaganfall?
Wissen Sie vielleicht eine Bluthochdruck, oder?
Was dahinter steckt, weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass sie eben diesen Schlaganfall gehabt hat.
Okay.
Sie habe aber gerade halbseitig Lehmung.
Können Sie laufen oder Sie müssen durchstehen?
Sie ist hilfsbedürftig, aber sie ist nicht komplett halbseitig gelebt.
Also Sie hat nur eine Einschränkung, ne?
Okay, verstehe.
Und Herr Leisen, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind renter.
Na ja, völlig bin ich renter.
Seit wann sind Sie renter?
Ja, lassen Sie mich überlegen, wie lange ist man denn im Ruhestand so 15 Jahre ungefähr?
Okay.
Hab es sich stressen im Leben?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Gut.
Und sind Sie verheiratet, oder?
Ich bin seit 30 Jahren verwittet.
Darf ich fragen, woher Ihre Frau gestorben ist?
Sie ist im Rahmen eines Verkehrsunfalls um Leben gekommen.
Oh, ist das nicht so leicht.
Verkehrsunfall.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind aber erwachsen natürlich, ne?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Drei.
Sind Sie gesund?
So viel ich weiß, ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Die sind ja auch nicht mehr so jung, also die haben wahrscheinlich auch so das, was alle haben, aber...
Okay, verstehe.
Also keine schweren Krankheiten.
Herr Leisen, wohnen Sie allein, oder?
Nein, ich hab eine Partnerin seit 10 Jahren und mit der lebe ich jetzt zusammen.
Ja, Partnerin.
Okay.
Und treiben Sie sportigelmäßig?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Früher habe ich so gerne Fußball gespielt und bin auch viel Fahrrad gefahren, aber das mache ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich gehe noch gerne spazieren.
Okay.
Herr Leisen, sind Sie in letzter Zeit ins Ausland gewesen?
Immer aus Land bin ich nicht gewesen, nein.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Traumodeverletzungen?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich mich irgendwo verletzt habe, nein.
Gut. Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft, ja.
Das hat man ja allen Leuten empfohlen, ja.
Mhm.
Okay, wie viele Mal?
Jetzt schon das fünfte Mal.
Okay.
Verstehe.
Ich habe wichtige Fragen für Sie, Herr Leisen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzugehen?
Ja, ich möchte eigentlich jetzt nur wissen, was hinter dieser komischen Veränderung steckt,
warum es mir so schlecht geht und vor allem natürlich, was man dagegen tun kann.
Mhm.
Herr Leisen, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Ich habe Verdach für Sie.
Ich denke, Sie haben eine, ja, viel langen Entzündung,
aber ich muss ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ihren Liftknoten muss ich untersuchen durchführen.
Und Labo und...
Was für eine Untersuchung müssen Sie bei den Liftknoten machen?
Ja, ich muss Ihren Halsbereich untersuchen.
Ja, aber gerade nur mit Abtasten, oder wie?
Ja, und danach natürlich, ich würde gerne eine Ultraschall durchführen.
Ja, eine Ultraschall ist ja auch eine kleine Untersuchung, ja.
Ich muss Röntgen-Torax veranlassen.
Auf jeden Fall, ich muss...
Ich muss auf jeden Fall ein Röntgen-Torax veranlassen, ja.
Aber Herr Leisen, Sie haben Probleme, Sie haben keine Appetit
und fünf Kilo abgenommen, Sie fühlen sich schlapp.
Deswegen bin ich ja gekommen, ja.
Deswegen muss ich ausführliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
Welche Untersuchungen, also außer den Liftknoten,
was machen Sie noch für Untersuchungen und den Röntgen-Torax?
Ja, natürlich, zuerst muss ich körperliche Untersuchungen,
Liftknoten untersuchen.
Das haben Sie ja schon gesagt, ja.
Was für Untersuchungen kommen noch?
Ja, natürlich, ich muss Ihren Bauch untersuchen durchführen,
damit Ihre vielleicht leber, vergrößerte Leber,
vergrößerte Milchs ausschließen können.
Ihren Leistenbereich und Achselhöhe abtasten.
Ah, ja, das ist verständlich.
Ja, aber ich muss ausführliche.
Ich muss Ihren Köpen ausführliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wenn ich eine Liftknoten feststellen kann,
der Liftknoten sind doch immer da.
Festgestellt habe, kann ich diese Liftknoten
wegen einer histologischen Untersuchung entfernen.
Die Liftknoten werden entfernt?
Ja, ich würde gerne planen.
Ja, okay, aber erst mal muss man noch gucken,
was damit los ist, oder?
Ja, natürlich, nach dem Laboruntersuchung.
Ah, Laboruntersuchung müssen Sie auch noch machen?
Ich darf für Sie eine Blut abnehmen.
Vielleicht eine große Blutbild.
Und diese Blutbild kann ich,
ich denke, gute Entscheidungen treffen.
Wenn Sie das Blutbild gesehen haben,
können Sie mir sagen.
Okay, gut, okay.
Ja.
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Wo kann ich hingehen?
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie sich Platz.
Ich habe Ihnen bescheid, aber mache Sie sich keine Stress.
Alles nicht so lange dauert.
Es dauert nicht so lange.
Okay, gut, dann bin ich ganz beruhigt.
Vielen Dank.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ein sehr faszinter?
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, nach Allergien ist nicht gefragt.
Er hat tatsächlich, ja, etwas harmlos, eine Erdbeerenallergie.
Ja, und die äußert sich mit Hautausschlag.
Hast du noch Fragen?
Ja, immer noch.
Also ja, Husten wird gefragt.
Er Husten habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Nein, ich meine, er hat es ja aber auch gefragt.
Und Haarausfall ist ihm nicht aufgefallen.
Aber er hat natürlich auch nicht mehr viele Haare.
Ein alter Mann, da fällt es nicht so auf.
Schluckstück, nur feste Nahrung oder nur flüssige Nahrung?
Bei flüssiger Nahrung fällt ihm das nicht auf.
Okay, können wir?
Ja.
Sie kommt noch eine Frage, ob ich mich unruhig fühle?
Nein, eigentlich, eigentlich, also nicht verstärkt.
Okay.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag Frau Obererzen.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Ja, es geht um Herr Jürgen Lozin.
Er ist 79 Jahre alt, 84 kg schwer, 1,78 m groß.
Herr Lozin starte sich bei uns wegen in Appetence seit ein,
wegen in Appetence vertrug.
Vertrug?
Sie habe erwähnt, dass er seinen Hausarzt hierhin geschickt habe.
Er hat nicht seinen Hausarzt geschickt, sondern seinen Hausarzt hat ihn geschickt.
Also er hat erwähnt, dass er Hausarzt ihn zu uns geschickt hat.
Ja, ich meine so.
Also er hat seine nächsten Begleitzentrums aufgefallen.
Er hat seine Temperatur und Ersatzung von 30 Grad.
Ja, aber seine Temperatur, ne?
Ja, seine Temperatur.
Ja, aus Erdem habe ich 5 kg in der Aktur, bis vier Wochen Abgenomen.
Ja.
Die Antwort er krank nun sein dem Folgen bekannt.
Discus prolapsus,
ich habe discus prolapsus.
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Ich habe das 600 mg morgens und abends einmal.
Er hat auch Hypolypidemie.
Er hat das 500 mg morgens und abends einmal.
Er hat auch Chroniciconjuctitis.
Er wurde als Kindheit.
Er war seit 18 Jahren nicht Rawha.
Vorher hat er 30 Jahre einen Schachter pro Tag geraucht.
Er hat das 500 mg morgens und abends einmal.
Er hat seit 15 Jahren Rente.
Er hat seine Frau seit 30 Jahren verstorben.
Er hat seit 10 Jahren einen festen Lebenspartner.
Er hat 3 Kinder und sie alle gesund sind.
Er betriebe keinen Sport.
Er wurde vom Ausland reisen.
Er hat eine Differenzialdiagnose im Kopf.
Er hat eine Differenzial-Blutbild.
Er hat eine Elektro-Lute.
Sie haben vollständig die Befundlage dargestellt.
Sie haben Gold interpretiert.
Sie haben die Befundlage verwendet.
Ich finde die Animes gespräch jedoch ein bisschen fehler, aber Arztarztgespräch gefällt mir sehr gut.
Frau Kollegin, Sie müssen Ihre medizinische Information aussehen.
Sie müssen Ihre sprachlich kompetenten Statue aussehen.
Sie meinen es verbessern.
Warum fragen Sie, wenn Sie Alkohol trinken?
Warum fragen Sie?
Warum haben Sie das mit einem Prüfungsprotokoll von einem anderen Kollegen?
Wenn Sie Alkohol bekommen, haben Sie Halsschmerzen.
Diese Frage ist nicht erforderlich.
Für Sie war es ein Punkt, der Sie weiter auf die Spur gebracht hat.
Ich habe kein Holzschirm, ich habe kein Wein.
Ich kann nur die Symptome schildern, die ich geschildert bekommen.
Ich habe da eine Fehlinformation gegeben.
Sie haben das nur sprachlich besser verpackt.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag.
Ich grüße Sie alle.
Guten Abend.
Danke.
Tschüss.